그래서 말씀해 주신 데가 다 서울
상권 내에서는 되게 괜찮은 지역인 거
같고 저는 여기뿐만
아니라 빌사남의 노크 안녕하세요
빌사남의 노크 김현수입니다 오늘
모실네 번째 게스트는 우리 회사에서
굉장한 긍정의 아이콘 유주원 중개사
님을 모시겠습니다 주원 중개사님
나와주세요 안녕하세요
어 안녕하세요 안녕하세요 어 저희
구독자 여러분들한테 간단하게 자기
저기 한번 부탁드리겠습니다네
안녕하세요 bsn 빌사 부동산
중개법인 유주원 팀장입니다 그럼 이제
바로 좀 사연을 만나 볼 건데 주원
중개사님 한번 읽어 주세요 아네
안녕하세요 제가 음식점을 10년 정도
운영하면서 열심히 살다 보니
25억이라는 돈을 모으게 되었습니다
요즘 임대료가 엄청 비싸잖아요 그래서
1월 바에는 내가 건물을 사서 그
건물에서 통 사업으로 사용하는게 더
낫다고 생각하게 됐는데요 지금 작년
11월부터 5개월 정도 물건을 계속
검토해도 사업을 해야 될 곳이라서
그런지 결정하기가 더 힘든 것
같습니다 마음에 드는 건물은 너무
비싸고 또 엄청 마음에 들진 않는데
그래도이 정도를 사야 되나라는 생각이
드는 건물들은 추후에 재매각이 되지
않을 것 같아서요 광진구 송파구
동대문구 쪽으로 보고 있습니다 대체
어떤 건물을 사야 나중에 후회하지
않고 성공적인 투자를 할 수 있을까요
일단은 10년 동안 2억이라는 돈은
정말
엄청나게 정사가 잘되는 곳이라고 좀
생각이 드는데 어떻게 생각하세요 일단
올해 동안 요식업을 하셨고 이제 내
건물에서 장사를 하고 싶다는 말씀이신
것 같은데 저는 이렇게 규모 있게
개인 사업하시는 분들께는 실사용
목적으로 건물
매입하시나요이랑 좀 다르게 보라
그러거든요 사용 하는 건물이 만약에
투자 가치가 좀 많이 없다라고 하면은
차라리 거긴 그냥
임대하고음 차라리 25억 가진 거
가지고 좀 투자가치 높은 데를
투자하라고 저는 좀 권하거나 어떻게
생각하세요 대표님 말씀대로 그런 투자
방향성도 굉장히 좋다라고 생각을
하는데 또 내 사업에서 내가 원하는
대로 인테리어를 충분히 하고 사업을
했을 때 사업 소득도 훨씬 증가할 수
있고 또 사업의 안정성이 확보가 되는
거라서 저는 사업을 매입하시나요
편이에요 만약에 이제 실 사용하실
분이라고 하면은 좀 어떤 건물을 좀
사는게 좋을까요 우선은 계속 요식업을
하셨던 분이고 앞으로도 하셔야 될
분이기 때문에 상권이 정말 중요할 것
같습니다 그런데 이제 또 뭐 반짝
떴다가 사라지는 그런 상권이 아니라
안정적이고 지속 가능한 상권을 좀
진입하셔야 될 것 같아요 그래서 주원
중개사님 딱 이렇게 추천하는 지역이
있으실까 일단은 이제 상권이
안정적이고 지속 가능하려면 주거지가
밀집되어 있어서 배우 세대
네피스 밀어 내가 물건을 매하는
지역에 돈을 소비하는 사람이 충분한
곳으로 보셔야 될 거 같고 지금 말씀
주신게 광진 송파 예 동대문구 이렇게
말씀을 주셨는데 일단 손과 쪽은 제가
한 세 가지 정도 상권이
떠오르더라고요 예 잠시 세내 상권
방역 상권 그리고 속리 단계 상권
상권의 색깔은 전부 다르지만
유동인구도 굉장히 많고 또 장사
잘되는 업장이 굉장히 많은 걸로 알고
있어요
네네 보 같 광진구는 광진구는 이제
대표적으로 제일 먼저 생각나는 상권은
사실 건대 입구역
상권이었다 로데오 거리라는 양꼬치
거리라는 오래된 구 상권으로 좀
안정적인 상권이자아요 제가 요즘 좀
눈여겨 보는 지역은 군자역 상권이든
군자역 이제 6번 추구 쪽으로 먹자
상권이 좀 형성되어 있는데 예전에
나혼자산다에 화사 씨가 거기 네 모
곱창집에서 이제 드시는게 방이 되면서
곱창집을 필두로 상권이 정말 크게
살아 났거든요 진자 개인적으로 굉장히
좋아해서 손님들께도 많이 추천드리고
저도 종종 가서 답사를 하면은 정말
그 현장감이 굉장히 좋다는 걸 느낄
수 있습니다 동대문 쪽은 어디
추천하세요 동대문은 사실 딱
생각나는게 패션타운이 아아 실제로
제가 20대 때는 두산 타워나
밀리오레 같은 쇼핑몰에 굉장히 자주
갔었어요 로 거기 가서 구매도 굉장히
많이 했던 기억이 있는데 실 요즘은
구매 패턴 자체가 온라인 쪽으로 많이
넘어온 상황이잖아요 그쪽 보다는
매입을 하신다면 저는 청양 이역
주변에 이제 상업지 쪽을 좀 하시는게
어떠실까 하는 생각이 들었거든요 그
그래서 말씀해 주신 데가 다 서울
상권 내에서는 되게 괜찮은 지역인 거
같고 저는 여기뿐만 아니라 제가 항상
말씀드리는 지역 그런데도 되게 괜찮을
거 같아요 성수동은 너무 좋고네
최근에 그래도 사람 많 뭐 신당동이
뭐 강남은 특히 좋고 근데 마포 쪽에
거기 홍대입구역 그쪽은 그래도
25억이면 충분히 들어갈 만한 것들이
꽤 있긴 해서 그쪽 지역도 좀 같이
보면 좋을 거 같고 강남구 내에서는
어디가 좀 제일 좋은 거 같어요 강남
구면 일단은 가장 이제 신사 청담을
좀 많이 선호하시는 것 같고 저도
추천을 신사 청담 쪽을 좀 많이
드리게 되는데 투자의 성격에 따라 좀
달라지기는 할 거 같아요 병원 운영을
목적으로 하신다거나
실제로 사용 목적을 하시는 분들은
더더욱 그쪽을 많이 보시는 거 같고요
임대소득 목적으로는 예전 같은
경우에는 뭐 노현동이나 역삼동 임면
쪽으로도 이제 개발 많이 하셔서
오피스 임차 맞추시는 그런 투자
방법도 많이 했지만 요즘은 사실
그렇게는 상황이 좋지 않은
상황이잖아요 임대 시장이 좋지 않다
보니까 강남부 쪽에서는 컨텐츠가 있는
분들은 그래도 메인 쪽으로 신사 청담
쪽으로 가시는게 좋지 않나라는 생각은
합니다 그럼 아예 그냥 실질적인
질문드리면 이제 25억에 만약에
주원중 대사님이 산다라고 하면 어디
사고 싶으세요네 얼마짜리
25억에 사실 근데 지금 7 80억에
100억 정도 사이에 수익률 나오는
깨끗한 건물 찾으시는 분이 정말
많아요 제 손님 중에도 많으시고 회사
내에서도 그런 손님들이 굉장히 많은
것으로 알고 있는데요 그래서 최근에
또 저희 회사에서 거래됐던 물건들을
보면 신당이 그지 뭐 합정 역이라는
이런 역세권에 깨끗한 건물 임차
탄탄하게 맞춰져 있는 건물 들 많이
보셨고 또 빠르게 그런 물건들이
거래가 됐어요 그래서 저는 만약에 7
80억 대다 하면은 신당역 주변에 좀
임차 잘 맞춰진 깨끗한 건물을
매입하지 않을까 그쪽도 괜찮고 또
약수역 주변도 상권이 굉장히 발달해
있잖아요 약수도 똑같이 이렇게 북쪽
방향으로 그쪽도 상권이 좋은데 거기도
괜찮은 건물들이 좀 있거든요 그래서
그쪽도 괜찮을 것 같습니다 만약에 뭐
이렇게 진짜 지경으로 운영 중이고 뭐
탄탄한 대 수익을 원한다고 하면 뭐
그런 지역도 저는 괜찮을 것 같습니다
그래서 만약에 지금 자영업하시는 분이
실질적으로 매입한다고 했을 때 어떤
거부터 좀 준비를 해야 될지를 좀
설명해 주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 건물
투자 하시데 있어서 뭐 개인이냐 법인
투자냐 이거를 먼저 생각해 보실 수
있을 것 같은데 최근 들어서 이제
법인 투자 하는데 있어서 약간의
허들이 조금씩 생기고 있어요 그래서
이렇게 실질적으로 뭐 요식업이 그지
개인 사업을 하고 계신 분들은 미리
법인을 좀 만드셨 가지고이 법인에서
매출이 발생을 할 수 있도록 상황을
좀 만들어 놓으시는 것도 굉장히
중요한 방법일 것 같아요 그래서
매출이 실제적으로 발생하는 법인에서의
대출 한도나 금리가 훨씬 더 유리할
수가 있거든요 그래서 그런 것들을
미리미리 준비하셔서 진행하시면 훨씬
더 좋은 조건으로 매입하실 수 있지
않을까 생각이 듭니다 은행에서 제일
싫어하는게 이제 부동산 임대업이 근데
이제 자영업하시는 분들은 메인이 있고
그리고 사실 사억 매인 용도로
산다라고 하면은 대출 조 워 좋아지기
때문에 지금 뭐 주원 중개사님
말씀해주신 것처럼 미리 설립을 한
다음에 매출을 그래도 어느 정도 좀
만들어 놓고 진짜 몇 천만 원이라도
예 만들어 놓고 빌딩 매입할 때
사용으로 산다라고 하시면은 대출
조건이 좋아지니까네이 점을
기억하셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고 혹시
뭐 마지막으로 하고 싶은 말 있으까요
저희는 뭐 워낙 물건 자체도 2만개
이상 보유하고 있고 또 손님들도
굉장히 많으시다 보니까 메인
매각하는데 있 최적화된 법인이 아닌가
싶거든요 그래서 뭐 물건 매입 매각
원하시는 분들 연락 많이 주시면 제가
성심성의 컷 열심히 좋은 물건
찾아드리고 매매도 진행 도와드리도록
하겠습니다 여기 인스타그램 아이디
뛰어드
여기네 많이 팔로우해 주세요 궁금한
거 있으면 메시지 주시면 될 것
같습니다네 오늘은 주원 중계사 님이랑
함께 해봤는데 여러분들도 추가적으로
궁금하신 거 있으시면 언제든지 댓글
남겨 주시면 감사하겠습니다 오늘
여기까지 하겠습니다 안녕 어 똑 똑
[음악]